AI is perhaps more dangerous than say
mismanaged aircraft design or production
maintenance or or bad car production in
the sense that it is it has the
potential how a small one make work on
that probability but it is non-trivial
it has the potential of civilizational
Destruction there's movies like
Terminator but it wouldn't quite happen
like Terminator because the intelligence
would be in the data centers the robot's
just the end effector in order for
civilization to advance we've got to
have freedom of speech I think in order
to really build trust you have to have
transparency it can't be that you have
this black box something's happening
getting in here we won't tell you what
it is trust us I think that's who yes if
you want to trust something you're going
to know how it works need motivation
watch the top 10 with believe Nation hey
it's Evan Carmichael and I make these
videos because as a young entrepreneur I
struggle to keep my business going I had
no friends I had no mentors I had no
role models and the thing that saved me
was learning from the success stories of
famous entrepreneurs and in their
stories I got motivation and I also got
strategies for what I could do to grow
my business and not stay stuck and I
still need their stories for motivation
today so today let's learn from one of
the best Elon Musk and my take on his
top 10 rules of success enjoy
how do you balance your life I mean with
this stress with so many different you
know you're on so many different company
parallel how do you balance it
well I I mean I I should point out that
I a 20-hour work day is uh relatively
unusual and and rather painful
um but but I I do sleep six hours a
night so
um and if I sleep less than six hours a
night I find that I am I might be awake
longer but I get less done so
um
but I I do have a work a ridiculous
amount I think relative to most people
and in that it's pretty much seven days
a week and mostly from when I wake up to
when I go to sleep
um I'm not suggesting this is good for
everyone and I think frankly I would
like to work a bit less on that so
um
say Tesla Tesla went through some very
difficult times where it was on the
Ragged edge of survival and and uh
really if I didn't give it everything I
got it the company could have easily
gone bankrupt it was really on the verge
of bankruptcy for quite a while
um I don't mean to suggest complacency
at this point but uh you know it does
require much less work to operate Tesla
Now versus say in the 2017 to 2019 time
frame
um
and it's not at Mortal risk of survives
it's achieved economies of scale that
make it you know not uh on the Ragged
edge of survival
um
and then the SpaceX also has a strong
team and is able to make a lot of
progress
um even if I spent less time there
um it does help if I spend time there
but uh you know it keeps making progress
even if I don't
um Twitter is still somewhat of a
startup in reverse and so there's a lot
of work required here to get Twitter to
a sort of a stable position
um
and uh like I said too
really build the engine of engineering
of software engineering at a Twitter and
have it um
you know really have a like a great
product roadmap and and the people in
place to implement that product roadmap
and so it is not my intention to work
um
like crazy
you know I mean I think I still I I
gotta be comfortable with a mere 80 hour
work week would be fine all right
uh and as per that is what I would
aspire to rule number two is fight for
freedom of speech what I think is is
essentially in order for
civilization to advance uh we've got to
have
um freedom of speech we've got to have a
digital yeah
so thank you
it's it's a bigger deal than you'd think
um and it's the kind of thing that
you don't know what you're missing until
you don't have it
and in a lot of places people don't have
it
and um
so it's important to bear in mind that
the nature of free speech is that the
acid test for it is
are people you don't like allowed to say
things that you don't like
otherwise it's not free
I can't it can't be just the things that
it can't be just things that you like
because eventually
somebody's not going to like what you
say
and they're going to shut you up
and that's that's the essence of free
speech and that's why it's the first
amendment in this country
and if we lose that
I think we lose the Bedrock of democracy
rule number three is promote AI safety
AI is
um
perhaps a
more dangerous than say mismanaged
aircraft design or production
maintenance or or bad car production in
the sense that it is
it has the potential how a small one
make regard that probability but it is
non-trivial it has the potential of
civilizational Destruction
there's movies like Terminator but it
wouldn't quite happen like Terminator
um because the the intelligence would be
in the data centers right the robot's
just the end effector
but I think perhaps what you may be
alluding to here is that
um
regulations are really only put into
effect after something terrible has
happened that's correct if that's the
case for AI and we only putting
regulations after something terrible has
happened it may be too late to actually
put the regulations in place the AI may
be in control at that point you think
that's real it is it is conceivable that
AI could take control and reach a point
where you couldn't turn it off and it
would be making
making the decisions for people yeah
absolutely absolutely no it's that's
that's definitely the where things are
headed
uh for sure uh
I mean um
the the things like like say uh chat EVT
which is based on jpt4 from open AI
which is the company that I
played a a critical role in in creating
unfortunately back when it was a
non-profit
yes
um
I mean the the reason uh opening eye
exists at all is that
um Larry Page and I used to be close
friends and I would stay at his house in
Palo Alto and I would talk to him later
tonight about uh AI safety and at least
my perception was that Larry was not
taking AI safety uh seriously enough
um and um what did he say about it he
really seemed to be
um
sort of digital super intelligence
basically digital God if you will uh as
soon as possible
um he wanted that
yes he's made many public statements
over the years uh that the whole goal of
Google is uh what's called AGI
artificial general intelligence or
artificial super intelligence you know
and I agree with him that the there's
great potential for good
um but there's also potential for bad
and so if if you've got some
um radical new technology you want to
try to take a set of actions that
maximize probably it will do good a
minimize probably will do bad things yes
it can't just be helpful either let's
just go you know barreling forward and
you know hope for the best rule number
four is maximize the use of Technology
how do you see technology in the next 10
years from now let's see 10 years it's
always difficult to predict technology
with Precision
um especially over a 10-year time frame
when it is changing so much
um
I mean there's there's obviously the
transition to sustainable energy uh with
the solar wind batteries and electric
vehicles
um and and that does if you look at the
percentage growth of that that is a very
high percentage growth although because
of the massive
industrial base of
um
yeah of the current sort of um fossil
fuel economy it it even like even if all
for example if electric cars were 100 of
production immediately it would take 20
years to replace the fleet so this is
still something that is quite gradual
you know it's measured in at least a few
you know 30 30 40 years type of time
frame the chat gbt I think has
Illustrated to
uh people just how advanced AI has
become
um because the AI has been Advanced for
a while it just didn't have a user
interface that was a accessible to most
people
um so what really child GPT has done is
just put in an accessible user interface
on AI technology that is
um this has been present for a few years
um and they're much more advanced
versions for that that are coming out
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five is innovate Elon
a question on
applying first principles thinking and
Innovation to an area that up to now has
seemingly been outside of of your
control and that is on mining and
extraction of some of the key materials
I believe a couple years ago you you had
a patent on sodium chloride to extract
lithium from some from some Clays and
small gyming clay and things of that
nature any how how does that fit into
the plan of maybe bringing real
Innovation into a mining sector that
could use a little you know maybe waking
up and getting those costs down because
that could be a real gating Factor it
seems
well we're we're going to address
whatever we think the limiting factor is
at any point in time uh so we would like
to do the least amount possible uh so we
don't want to get into the mining or
finding sector we will do that if we
have to
um
I I do think the the focus really should
be on refining capacity
um
you know do we need to make just a very
uh Giant
amount of anode cathode lithium
lithium hydroxide lithium lithium
carbonate it there's it's really the
refining capacity that is uh the the
biggest choke point
um
yeah so that's why we're building a
lithium refinery in Corpus Christi and
we're obviously building a cathode
processing facility just adjacent to
this this building so a little further
down the road you'll see another large
construction that's for a cathode
refining
um
the root likes it would really prefer if
others did that uh we're doing it
because we have to do it because we want
to rule number six is create
transparency I think in order to really
build trust you have to have
transparency it can't be that here's
this black box something's happening
here in here we won't tell you what it
is trust us I think that's BS
um if you want to trust something you're
going to know how it works and so the
that's why we're open sourcing the
algorithm now open sourcing algorithm is
kind of embarrassing people have found
all sorts of things that were wrong
and foolish and you know misguided with
with the algorithm and we've actually
fixed I think at this point over 100
issues with the algorithm
um so it's been it's actually been very
helpful to open source it and we're
going to open source the entire thing
that you basically you should be able to
recreate the probability of of a tweet
being recommended based on on the on
what we've open sourced if you can't
recreate it then we haven't shown you
everything that so it's it's really
complete transparency and that I think
that's the only path to trust I don't
think there's another path rule number
seven is read more and talk to smart
people I know you're a huge reader
um but from a
um a lifelong learning perspective
constantly trying to add to your toolkit
so that you're you know a better leader
a better CEO are there recommendations
that you have for the audience about
those kinds of things that you do to
keep yourself mentally Sharp
okay
well I read a lot less these days and I
used to when I was a kid I was read all
the time
um
I mean mostly subscribe to Scientific
periodicals like
um you know like the The Daily News I
find to be a lot of noise
um and just very negative uh so I
generally try to not read The Daily News
that much
um because generally newspapers try to
seem to be trying to answer the question
what is the worst thing that happened on
Earth today
it was big okay there's a lot of people
something terrible happened every single
day guaranteed it was a big big plan
also something great happened but they
don't answer that question
so that's the Daily News just tends to
make more miserable event like the
um scientific Science and Tech and
Technology periodicals are quite
interesting
um and usually you know if there's
something someone you're discovering
that it'll be in there
um
so and you know find Twitter
enlightening at times you know
learn learn about there and talking to
smart people all the time
uh is very helpful
um because that can be a distillation of
of interesting things that are going on
um
and you know it's certainly like try to
ask people like for the car like what
are we doing wrong you know what can we
expect what can we make it better and
they usually just want to tell me what's
right you know like the chart I
understand but what's wrong with it and
like what can we make better you know
like how do we be less wrong rule number
eight is focused on affordability what
is the nearest one Focus for you in
terms of ramping up the next gen vehicle
and how do you make sure that by
lowering the price point uh so much
because the cost is going down 50 you're
not cannibalizing demand you know for
your existing Vehicles demand for our
vehicles in terms of desire to own them
may as well be infinite
uh it's indistinguishable from infinite
at this point uh the affordability is
what matters so as you make the car more
affordable uh we will have demand to go
crazy basically
uh the issue is how do we build the cars
the hard part is building the cars
I cannot emphasize that enough the hard
part is building the cars and the entire
supply chain that goes with the cars
this is a
Logistics challenge
of extraordinary difficulty
um
all the things that have to go into a
car have to scale with the car
while everything is doing in an
exponential ramp
and if you miss even one of those things
doesn't matter why earthquake flood fire
Revolution
I thought I've heard them all I mean
any part of that supply chain gets
interrupted
you're now then you have a seizure
the hard part is building the cars
by far
and the supply chain that goes with it
rule number nine is hire good people
when you
hire people or really what you're trying
to when you hire people that just means
you're convincing people to join you in
in the Endeavor
um
you should hire people
that are that are also passionate about
what you're doing so it's not just that
they're not just there for the salary
they really need to care about what
they're doing
and and then they will stay during the
dark times and Rule Number 10 the last
one before some very special bonus Clips
is think long term how do you see
Twitter if we we say it five years down
the road
what's your vision for for this platform
I have the sort of long-term Vision
something called uh x.com from back way
back in the day uh which is kind of like
a
um sort of like an everything app
um where it's just maximally useful it
does you know payments uh does
um
uh so it provides Financial Services
provides information flow
um really anything digital
um and um
it also provides secure Communications
um
so it relates to
you know I think it'll be as useful as
possible as entertaining as possible
um and also to be like a a source of of
Truth like if you want to uh
find out what's going on and what's
really going on
um then you could be able to go on on
you know X the X app and uh
and and find out
so it's a sort of source a sort of a
source of Truth and a maximally useful
I guess app is about the wrong word but
system
um and Twitter is essentially an
accelerant to that sort of maximal
useful everything app
how do you deal with the people who say
no you are shooting too far ahead you
are trying to do something that's
impossible don't bother doing it or uh
or are resistant to change how do you
manage those that resistance the
naysayers out there and continue on
well I would go back to physics in that
um the only things that are truly
impossible break from physics
um so as long as you're not breaking
laws of physics
um it's possible it doesn't matter what
anyone's opinion is
um you know physics is the law and
everything else is a recommendation I've
seen plenty of people break the law but
I've never seen anyone break physics
anything within the laws of physics is
possible
yeah I mean and you can certainly
challenge laws of physics but uh they've
been challenged quite well and uh have
found to be resilient they focus on on
signal over noise
a lot of companies get get confused they
spend money on things that don't
actually make the product better for
example at Tesla we've we've never spent
any money on appetizing
we've put all the money into r d and
Manufacturing and design to try to make
the car as good as possible
um and uh I think that's that's the way
to go for for any given company just can
keep thinking about
are these efforts that people are are
expanding are they resulting in a better
product or service and if they're not
stop those efforts it's hard to say
because things have worked out pretty
well in the end so how how big of a
mistake could it have been as the
question is really really asking
um
uh you know I did lots of dumb things at
my first company and at PayPal
um
and uh
and you know I think I think sometimes I
yeah but I don't know there's so many I
like I'm hard pressed to say this is
this is the biggest one you know give
this one or two
okay
um
okay sure um so there
the biggest mistake in general that I've
made and I'm trying to correct for that
is
uh to put too much of a waiting on
somebody's talent and not enough on
their personality
and I've made that mistake several times
in fact
then I would say actually I'm not gonna
make that mistake again they don't make
it again
um and and I think it actually matters
uh whether somebody has a good heart it
really does
and I've made I've made the mistake of
thinking that sometimes it's just about
the brain what were your biggest
obstacles or mistakes
that you have faced and how did you
overcame it and maybe you can also give
us the students here a piece of advice
and that will be very amazing thank you
[Applause]
well to be frank I've made so many
mistakes that it would take far too long
for me to list them all
um
so I I would know one of both people
with the extremely long list of mistakes
that I've made in the past
um but I think that the the higher
principle here is that it is always too
aspire to be less wrong over time so to
acknowledge that you'll always be to
some degree wrong but that you wish to
be less wrong over time and and uh
and if you can be a little less wrong
every day I think you're doing great
um it's it's hard to be less wrong every
day but frankly even if you do that's
wrong most days that that's a pretty big
victory
um
you know a number of things that I've
said before publicly so
um you know I think it's important to to
place weight upon both the heart and the
mind not simply the mind
um some of the biggest mistakes that
I've made in terms of hiring people have
been when they were
strong of mind but not apart the hybrid
higher principle is just assume you're
wrong and you want to be less wrong and
just try to be less wrong every day
um seek critical feedback especially
from Friends
um often your friends will know what
what you are what what you're saying is
wrong but they don't want to hurt your
feelings so they won't tell you but if
you ask them to tell you and say that it
won't hurt your feelings then they will
tell you
so I think getting critical feedback
from friends is very helpful and now is
the time to take risk you don't have
kids as you get older your obligations
increase so you're the and once you have
a family you start taking risk not just
for yourself but for your family as well
it gets much harder to do things that
might not work out
so now is the time to do that uh before
you before you have those obligations so
I would encourage you to take risks now
do something bold
um you won't regret it I would say
try to learn as much as much
as possible that allows you to predict
the future or make the future say the
same is the best way to predict the
future is to make it
um
just and then assess whether what you're
learning is
enabling you to predict the future with
less error
are you less wrong
we're always wrong to some degree
but can you reduce the error on your
future predictions I think that's the
way to look at education
as of course but with both creative
create the future and predict the future
so that includes art and all those other
things
but close the loop on being less wrong
about future
I would say that's the right way to
think about education
I mean down the road with the neural
link
you can just upload any subject
instantly so we like the Matrix we want
to fly a helicopter no problem well
helicopters will fly themselves but you
know if you wanted to do whatever any
given skill you just upload it instantly
um and the way Education Works right now
it's extremely low bandwidth it's
extremely slow
lectures are the worst really it was
like very slow you know
um
yeah
just
try to predict the future with less
error this is the hard this is very hard
as you were saying I'm not sure it's
99.9 but it's it's not very good
generally a prediction of the future but
I think often people don't try the first
thing is try if you don't try okay
you know you've got to try and then and
then adjust based on the error of your
prior predictions
did you figure you were going to start a
car company and be successful at it well
I didn't really think Tesla would be
successful I thought we would most
likely fail but I thought that we at
least could address the false perception
that people had that electric car had to
be ugly and slow and and boring like a
golf cart but you say you didn't expect
the company to be successful then why
try if something's important enough you
should try even if you the probable
outcome is failure I was uh I was always
kind of like a crazy kid I suppose um
I was just very curious about the world
and
um
how do we come to be here what's the
meaning of life and all that and uh
um I always had a really intense desire
to understand things and learn
um
yeah I mean I had sort of an existential
crisis I guess when I was on a
11 or 12 or something trying to figure
out what it's all about you know and uh
ultimate cage came to the conclusion
that um
we don't really know the answer but
uh but if we increase the scope and
scale of civilization then we uh we have
a much better chance of understanding
the meaning of life and why we're here
or even what other right questions to
ask so therefore we should strive to
expand the scope and scale of
consciousness
to better understand
the questions to ask about the answer
that is the universe where do you go to
both personally
intellectually as engineer as a team
like for source of strength needed to
sort of persevere through this
and to keep going with the project take
it to completion a source of strength I
doesn't really know how I think about
things
um
I mean for me it's simply this this is
something that is important to get done
um and we we should just keep doing it
um or die trying
and I I don't need
a source of strength so quitting is not
even like
um that's not it's not in my nature okay
and I I don't
care about optimism or pessimism
that we're going to get it done okay
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
when I interview someone to work at the
companies would be to ask them to tell
me about the problems that they worked
on and how they solved them and
if someone was really the person that
solved it they'll be able to answer
multiple levels they'll be able to go
down to the price tax and if they
weren't they'll get stuck
and then you can say oh this person was
not really the person who solved it
because anyone who struggled hard with a
problem never forgets it why do we need
to build a city on Mars with a million
people on it in your lifetime which I
think is kind of what you've said you'd
love to do
yeah I think it's important to have
a future that is inspiring and appealing
I mean I just think that they're like
there have to be reasons that you get up
in the morning and you want to live
like why do you want to live what's the
point what what inspires you what what
do you love about the future and if if
we're not out there if the future does
not include being out there Among the
Stars
and being a multi-planet species I find
that
it's incredibly depressing if that's not
the future that we're going to have I
think the
the value of beauty and inspiration is
very much underrated no question
um but I want to be clear I like I'm not
trying to be anyone's savior uh that is
not the I I'm just trying to
think about the future and not be sad I
think I'm kind of constitutionally just
geared to to just keep going I don't
know
um
it's a
yeah I mean it just I
I don't know I mean it certainly there
are times when
you know things don't go well and then
uh that's quite desperating for sure
um and so then it's it's difficult to
proceed with the same level of
enthusiasm but
um but I do think like I do think the
things that we're doing are are you know
pretty important to the Future
um and if we don't succeed then you know
there's well there's there's not it's
not clear what other things would
succeed
um and if if we don't succeed then we'll
be certainly pointed to as a reason why
people shouldn't even try for these
things so I think it's important that we
do whatever is necessary to keep going
if you're trying to convince the public
to do something you have to say okay
how's this going to read and what
message are we going to try to convey
what will people respond to what would I
respond to if I was you know sort of an
objective member of the public and um so
that's that's really you know if you're
trying to change people's minds or get
people fired up about something then you
got to think okay what's that message
what what's going to get them really
excited the reason I got into space was
to try to increase NASA's budget
all right
[Music]
and but so I'll tell you so the
roundabout way I thought that might be
accomplished was
um I thought well if if NASA's budget
was more was larger than we could do
more in space exploration and I thought
well what well particularly if we could
get the public excited about sending
people to Mars and I thought well if I
could do a small greenhouse and and send
that to the surface of Mars with seeds
in in
nutrient gel and you hydrate the gel and
Landing you have a little miniature
greenhouse and then you'd have the
public tends to get excited about
precedence and superlatives so it'll be
like the
you know sort of first life on Mars the
furthest lives ever traveled and you get
people sort of excited about war but
where would you send people there like
the hell of plants we should send people
you know right right
um and um and then um I thought well
that could if that could get the public
really excited about sending fuel to
Mars then that would translate into
Congressional support for a bigger NASA
budget that was the goal and then I
didn't have enough money to buy uh and I
thought that that outcome would have 100
chance of no no commercial success
so the 100 chance of losing all the
money so
um so compared to that SpaceX which I
thought maybe had a 10 chance of success
that was an improvement
foreign
video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
it's a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome pretend more amazing rules from
Jeff Bezos check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there don't try to chase what is kind of
the hot Passion of the day I think we
saw it in the internet World quite a bit
where you know at the sort of peak of
the internet in say 1999 found people